[Music]
everybody in the Cobian and I'm glad to
be back on my GM in residence for the
next three weeks and today is gonna be a
class on endgame so I prepared several
positions that I want to show you and
the first time we're gonna start out
with a very famous position and you some
of you might know this but I think it
would be useful to go over it for some
people who don't know it or even for
some players who perhaps maybe forgot a
little bit okay so this position you
know we have is white to play and win
okay this is a famous Lucena position so
the the most important thing about this
position here guys that you have is that
you have the rook cutting off the Kings
the King cannot cross okay King cannot
cross so they remember that okay so if
King somehow crosses it's most likely
going to be a draw so you have to
remember that so if your last one was
rook e1 from a1 to e1 I will be in a
fantastic move cut the King off and the
idea of cut the king in a rook end game
is extremely extremely important okay so
you gotta remember that so in this
position we're gonna start we have a few
ways a few things we have to do in order
to win this the goal number one is
trying to advance our upon so we're
gonna have some moves
brookey to f5 let's say stays here King
g6 check here
now you go roopd one check now the King
cannot go here cannot go any of the
score so he has to go back okay so
that's that's great because now he is
further away he is further away now from
the pawn okay that's perfect so now we
continue push okay
now you have to try the next plan
hereafter let's say he waits here next
step is we're gonna try to continue
advancing our pond okay now f7 and now
opponent is gonna play the most
challenging move rook g2 if it doesn't
play root G to let's say plays rook f3
I'm gonna play rook g1 King D 7 yourself
King g7 rook e1 check goes here f8 Queen
takes King takes and white is winning
white is winning quite easily so that's
why the idea is to play rook C 1 so
that's why I play rook g2 to try to
protect the position now the idea is try
to prevent ticking from coming in here
and now I want to give you a few minutes
to find you know 2 minutes thinking for
you okay to see white white to play what
is the correct idea to try to find a win
anybody maybe you can type in the chat
here so I can see your answer here
what's this idea called here what is
this idea called everybody okay perfect
yeah so I can see several people typing
a deal a deal my friend a deal McDonald
AI very and few other people let's see
rugby for ook before but I need somebody
to mention the idea dice you're saying a
move explain the idea why you're
suggesting that move okay
why are you suggesting the move what
what plan
Lucina lucena okay you're trying to
build do Lucena position by playing
rugby for now after that he will play
let's say rook g'wan and now build the
bridge correct goo Roth correct graph
enricher 10 everybody perfect now check
King goes on f6 check
King goes here check King goes here
check rook F 4 and now if takes King
we'll take it ok takes king we'll take
it and then you promote upon with afraid
okay okay
promote the pawning to a queen
so remember once you get this position
the king has to be two squares away from
the pond so he cannot catch him then you
will go here and you'll see now the king
is further away from the pond you cannot
catch it okay now what what example
let's say he goes here now what are you
gonna do let's say he goes here now
you're gonna try to bring the bridge
closer now you're gonna try to bring the
bridge closer okay so you go here now he
goes here
rook f5 takes King takes and now you can
promote the pawn into a queen okay so
remember that f8 Queen
okay once again some of you are familiar
with this but I think it was very
important to go over it again and if you
had this position let's go back to the
original position let's say your rook is
somewhere else let's say the rook is not
only one you want to make sure you if
you are in a position like this you're
winning move is rook e1 once again with
the idea is to cut the King off okay so
remember that next position I have for
you we're gonna talk about some King and
pawn and games here okay we're gonna
talk about some keying and pawn in games
so this one white to play why to play
and win
now
this one is opposition okay
eBay yet to the triangulation you have
to use a triangulation to win the
opposition okay triangulation
who can explain in a chat what is
triangulation what is the basic basic
idea of triangulation what is that I
know you typing triangulation yes
triangulate but the point of
triangulation is you basically want to
achieve the same position but with
opponents turn technically yes
it's called lose a temple lose a tempie
okay so you have to remember that okay
lose a Tempe remember that so now you
play Katie five this is one of the more
complicated triangulations okay so now
he goes King c8 now you may think like
wait a minute I can come here
he can go here I can come here he can go
here and then we have a souk subong okay
we have a Suk's of an here okay so
that's a problem you know and it's gonna
be a draw here so that's why we have to
do something here that will be a still
mate so now how can you reach the same
position with opponents turn king c-4
that is a good suggestion now if he
comes here then you go king c5 and you
have the opposition and your king will
sneak to b6 and pick up a 6m win the
game so he will play King c4 let's say
he goes here King d8 now you play King
before now he goes here king c8 and now
King D 5 the point here is if he goes to
c7 he go king c5 if he goes to this six
you go kin d6 king c8 you go c7 king b7
King deservin king c7 and now do you
want a queen here
do you wanna Quinn no because if you
Quinn it's gonna be what I still made so
that's why you don't want to rush here
nope I don't want you to get a rook here
the rook is gonna take too long I need
you to find the checkmate in three who
can type in the chat checkmate in three
guys I know you're saying look but I
need you to be most effective okay most
effective here King c6 now he goes here
c8 Queen check and now Queen p7 mate
okay
when you gotta make perfect alright so
once again understanding the what's
triangulation you want to lose a Tempe
when you're doing a triangulation guys
remember that that's what you're trying
to do when you do the triangulation next
C I will bring one more but this is very
simple we're gonna go over this really
quickly because this is a very simple
same idea triangulation but very simple
one
compared to other one but still useful
to know why to play and win here and
again you will just use the method of
triangulation okay how are you gonna do
that how can we do the triangulation
here to again we just simply want to
achieve the same position with the
opponent's turn here okay you can do
kindy too or you can start out with
kingi to all even kings it - it doesn't
really matter so let's say King did you
now the point is he has to stick with f6
square because if it tries to come here
to win the pants you're gonna go have
six f7 you're gonna Quinn if you go see
it you're gonna continue push here
you're gonna go here simply g5 and you
just white is just winning so he has to
go King of six nine goes king f6 now
triangulate you have to triangulate
kink e to correct Zachary correct a deal
cos T correct Richard yeah perfectly
well not King the three guys not King to
twist even Radu if you go King III then
it's the same position King defies you
don't want to do that
remember we try to lose a move here so
kinky too perfect
why not clean the twistiest even if you
go King D three King G five it's the
same exact position okay we don't
accomplish much so that's why we want to
go here first King e2 now when it goes
kingly five then you go kin D 3 and now
you achieve the triangulation you
understand now he steps away thank you
very much okay if he goes here we push
he goes here we push got it
so remember that okay if he steps away
you're just gonna push the pawns
alright so again quite simple
triangulation again the point of
triangulation is reach the same position
with the polyester so essentially lose
lose a move okay so remember to lose the
move remember all right since we're on
the King and pawn topic here I want to
make sure you are familiar with this
position some of them you might seen in
my previous videos so but I have some
new ones as well for you so this one
white to play and there is a way for you
to make a draw here how can you do it
why to play and draw which method you're
going to use here to make a draw
so here we we're trying to use the idea
called distant opposition okay okay
we have several opposition's guys we
have a regular opposition we have a
diagonal opposition we have a distant
opposition okay
so one of the most important things you
have to know this different types of
opposition's okay because knowing that
this will help you in your end games so
here which move I see several people
typing the correct move yes opposition
whenever we're talking about the
opposition it should be odd number of
squares between your king and opponent's
king so the opposition is king h1 now he
goes here that's the opposition okay odd
number of squares will give you the
opposition now he goes here what do you
do
King here
he goes here King here
now he goes here king it you can't cheat
you
now goes here then again you achieve the
opposition again don't don't try to go
after the pawns here okay
again your objective is not to try to
win the pawns here because if you do
that guess what he's gonna get behind it
and push you away you're gonna lose now
you're gonna lose the pawn okay you
don't want that to happen okay this this
this this this so here you will just
stay with the King g3 okay now King beat
you King h1 and now the last trick here
last trick last attempt here GE for now
g4 is plating again we have to think
Great Wolf will go over the difference
can you show how King f1 doesn't work
sure I presume in original position
writing a song King f1 the optimist he
goes here you go here and now look at
this this pawn is on your way you cannot
keep the opposition because of that okay
because now you're gonna lose so you're
gonna go here and he's gonna get the
opposition on you and then he's gonna
get behind it and push you away from
your pawn and then he's gonna Quinn okay
so that's what you gotta try to see
that's your difference okay so you don't
that's what you gotta try to do so now
let's say he plays chief ward and now if
you take you're gonna be in serious
trouble okay because if you take he's
gonna push sorry if you take is gonna
push you push you push you push you push
you push equals with the check okay
he Queens with the check and now it's
gonna be a trouble okay okay
so that's why when he goes here g4 we
don't want to take here we're just
simply gonna go King G - correct
now if it takes we're gonna take back
with the king he goes here King g4 and
you're gonna pick up the pawn
okay so block is gonna try to set up the
last shop for you
King d2 now he takes you push takes you
push here you push and what's gonna
happen here now your king is no longer
on a background here it's not in the
background so you're gonna simply Quinn
and it's a drill but once again I want
to make sure you don't play the blunder
here in this kind of positions don't go
up guys stay on a background okay still
in a background so you don't get
skewered or something okay stay on the
background that's the key for you to
remember okay you must stay on a
background okay very good
okay a very important position for you
to know and we talked about the
opposition's so this is part of that
opposition guys and here you have to I
don't want to say anything I just want
you to find it okay
block to play and win okay block to play
and win
can you please calculate the idea
because look rook and a bishop versus
rook is a draw okay so now you're
getting ready to lose the G Force so
what are you going to do here what can
you do in this position
now what can we do here
okay let's see here take steak steak
steak steaks
I'm knocking your six Zachery not king
of six takes six takes King the 44
correct a deal correct a deal
alright Marcin correct here let's see
who else not king of six guys not king
of six because yeah this is this is an
opposition but this is a little bit
different kind of opposition okay so you
got to get closer to the pawns okay here
so it's important for you to get closer
to the pants because you want to win the
pawn here okay so that's why you wanna
done you want to try to go King to d4
okay and you want to shoulder away
rolled it away the king okay now King
before King did three now you're
shouldering him away
Kinki to king f2 now he takes back on
gt9 goes kim jiwan's
now he's trying to achieve the
opposition okay now he's trying to
achieve the opposition so now what's the
correct move here it's still not too
late to make a mistake and let upon and
to slip away here guys but you're not
gonna let that happen you're gonna find
a correct move here what's the correct
move here okay correct correct King
correct yes
King h3 what you trying to tell them
basically tell him go away go away
basically that's what you're trying to
tell them okay go away from the corner
if let's say you go here he's gonna go
here you're gonna push he's gonna go
here you're gonna push she's gonna go
here you're gonna go here and that's
gonna be a stalemate
okay got it so you don't want that and
also you don't wanna taking F two
because that would be a stalemate as
well so that's why you're simply gonna
go King h3 he goes king h1 you push
he push you push you push you push and
Quinn got it perfect and that's how
you're gonna get the win so once again
the topic for this one is this actually
happens similar position happened in the
game mama D are off Nakamura okay in
Olympiad look at the game guys 2014
chess olympiad match last round match I
believe USA vs. Azerbaijan look at that
game okay it's very it's just Mahmud II
era was playing wide so he sucked on f7
basically okay but I wanna add a detail
about this okay I'm gonna add a detail
here I want to add something here to see
now it's a game block to play here okay
block to play here my question to you
here is my question
something with a chest space here let's
see
because it's glitching the chest bass
noodles yeah too many windows open no
just happened yeah I'll kiss hurry up
well okay okay one second guys we gonna
restart the chest space okay
I don't know what's going on with the
chest pace and funding maybe not even a
chest piece it's yeah
so what should I do Ben
you
okay guys we are back sorry
let it let it Inc a glitch with the
computer okay sorry about that but let's
get it going so I hope you had time to
look up that game okay since I had a
little technical technical difficulty
here did you guys let anybody look up
that game that I mentioned when I
explained you things I like to reference
games because I think it will help you
to remember better you know that's what
I do with my students my private
students as well whenever I'm showing
them some openings I like to bring some
reference games here okay for you okay
now what to do here guys
if can can you take on f2 here and
assume that you're gonna be able to win
same same concept here right
take-take-take is this position winning
here or there is a miracle miracle safe
maybe here for white yeah this was a
Windows Windows problem guys
so we had to reboot the computer anybody
found that game yeah yeah yeah now come
well I think my MIDI arrow was white I
think I think but maybe I'm wrong
mhm all right what's the plan here well
cos T cos T if you play H world I play
King at e3 you lose the pants let's see
here Y place h-hold and it's a draw a
deal how's this a draw King bee tree I
will shoulder you out a deal focus focus
okay this is a serious stuff here I
think unfortunately Hikaru - kanji for
earlier so he didn't he didn't have this
resource okay but here white has a
fantastic resource guys you have a
fantastic resource
why it is a fantastic resource here
what's the resources or nah-nah-nah King
f1 guys King f1 I go King III now the
correct resource I see is wait no not
for still made guys it's not gonna be a
still made here kingi - correct just two
players cos T and devaglia
the Avakian our ado suggesting it guys
now the point being here is if he takes
you will go back and as we know the
corner pants I've drawn you can have six
pounds here if you want it's Duke and
you're not gonna be able to break
through okay you could have six pounds
it's still gonna be a draw okay so now
he's gonna go here he's gonna claim the
opposition but as soon as she claims the
opposition you have a move here to win
the opposition and that movie here is h4
and suddenly he has to move his king and
you are the one with the opposition okay
you are the one with the opposition okay
he goes here you go here he goes here I
go here and you will be able to win this
game
alright so you have to remember that
this is very very important okay idea so
keep in mind this resource of King
g-tube you leave the tension you leave
the tension for your advantage okay you
leave the tension for your advantage to
break okay so remember King g4 then you
will play then you play h4 alright so
keep this in mind okay so here you know
if you go rook if you block here you
play rook F - it's not gonna be a win
okay it's not gonna be way can you show
how when after after opposition after
opposition how well well you have to pay
king it you guys
and now King before it's a draw
you cannot win in this position it's
it's it's it's our position so he goes
here you go here he goes here you go
here it's a draw ok ok I hope everybody
understand this position ok moving
forward ok
all right let me ask you this year how
many of you studied opposite color
endgame bishops ok no no triangulation
no it doesn't work no how many of you
studied some opposite color endgame
positions and know the concept of this
please type in a child that you familiar
with opposite color bishops well I've
been doing it for a very long time
that's how I remember this I've been
playing chess for 30 31 years now so and
I've been coaching for close to 20 years
so yeah just a lot of lot of experience
and a lot of effort ok all right
opposite color yeah well yeah I mean
hundred end games you need to know but
my stuff is maybe 25 25 must end games
so this is what I teach to my students
you know all my private students they
have to know this 25 position is that a
course okay you went to this course
you're gonna graduate knowing your
basics most important endgame positions
okay so here one thing you should know
is if you allow opponent to connected
pass on to reach the sixth rank and
they're not black you're gonna lose once
again I repeat if you let them reach the
sixth rank and you don't block them you
are going to lose okay so remember that
okay so that's why we are going to play
how are we going to stop it we have
several ways we can try to stop we can
try to play Bishop g4 we can try to do
other things but how can we stop it
yeah well yeah I'm very familiar with
what etske and game on well it's it's a
very good book but it says I think it's
made for more advanced players you know
probably over 2,000 2,100 maybe
mm-hmm so now what's the idea here
anybody what's the approach here we can
defend from the back we can defend from
the side we can defend you know from g4
but what's the correct approach here
here you have to use what's called the
active defense active defense you have
to use here you know if you're
interested in private lessons just go to
my website guys every everything is
there okay so you just go to my website
you will find more information okay so
let's focus on the the class here so
most important thing is Bishop h7 Bishop
h5h / 7 correct approach this is called
defending from the front okay defending
from a front so he goes here and then
you bring the bishop here look at this
he goes here thank you very much thank
you very much okay and you win if he
goes here d6 you go Bishop e6 and you
cement the position okay you same mental
position got it
so remember you play Bishop h5 e 5
Bishop f7 if you play d6
you go Bishop e6 lock it at the position
if you play c6 I take takes King takes
c6 got it
okay
and here he can try to go here you go
here you wait he goes here you are here
you go here because here I will here
if he plays d6 you go Bishop e6 again
you keep the blockade on okay blockade
on in this position if you place each
six you're gonna take take and take got
it
so one thing about this you have to
remember you want to do an active
defense okay active defense attack from
the front okay alright next position is
gonna require some serious calculation
so this is for players who will be able
to calculate very long okay all right
white to play and win okay why to play
and win my website is just my last name
guys echo being calm okay if you go
there you'll find information about my
games my lessons about me okay
so just you have to type my last name
comm so white to play and win okay
why to play and win but how how you're
going to do that here okay
very very important
how we are going to do that yeah
yeah it's about losing yeah it's about
losing some Tempe here once again if
you're breaking if or unfortunately I
play c5 okay
unfortunately I play c5 and now King the
five I have I have d3 if you go here I
go here and I go here unfortunately it's
gonna be a draw so it's not about going
there directly you have to think little
bit okay you have to think little bit
kingi five guys what are you going
trying to lose the game
be careful huh we have to kind of lose a
move here okay we have to kind of lose a
Tempe here so and in order to lose the
Tempe yes we can go King f3 correct now
he plays c6 is waiting for you and now
again if you go King before he plays c5
don't rush don't rush a deal all you
have to do first
King f4 correct now you can play c5 but
you pick your weak angle here is the
same thing so let's say you go see well
this is just losing King g5 now this is
just easily your winning mate okay so he
has to play c5 now what do you do
now what do you do
now kingi for correct now opponent is
gonna go here to e8 now what can you do
here
King d5 if you play the three kingi six
you pay d2 and now you have f7 checkmate
so he has to go Kings d7 to oppose you
yes you should study everybody should
study more in games okay because a lot
of times you will get into these
positions and you have want to have the
knowledge you you're not gonna know
exactly but you want to build the
knowledge okay that knowledge will help
you to understand what to do now what's
the move here important move here guys
and once again here he cannot play d3
because you're taking it is six and f7 a
so he has to go here now what do you do
Jinxy for correct now he has to go back
no choice so he goes back now what do
you do
now what's the winning move here yeah we
can take perfect attack in the pond he
goes here we can go here we can go here
he Queens and we're gonna mate here see
Bravo Bravo that's the correct idea okay
all right so once again here if it goes
here takes here here if you're looking
at seven I've King be seven here here
Queen and mate
perfect okay guys excellent job today I
hope you enjoyed the endgame class today
and we will be back I will be back with
you on Thursday okay for the another
clusters day evening by the meantime
there is a very excited exciting event
started today the clutch tres between
top four American players and this is a
very interesting matches Nakamura versus
so and Caruana versus Domingues so make
sure you tune in and watch that next
couple of days I should be very exciting
okay
but I will be back on Tuesday evening
for more lectures okay all right thanks
for joining guys and thanks for your
answers on the chat so see you on
Thursday everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]